[Music]
hey good afternoon my name is Dan
Thacker I'm the director of site
reliability and core engineering and
magically my team's mission and
magically is to provide technology
solutions and services to the rest of
the organization to enable people to do
and perform their best work we're a
globally distributed team we provide
24/7 365 support to our customers and
one of the challenges that we face is
being a global team is well apart from
daylight savings and realizing that New
Zealand actually goes the opposite
direction than the u.s. from the time
changes is to kind of maintain a sense
of team and maintain a sense of
community the team building so last year
we were casting around for ideas for how
can we do a team-building exercise and
we landed on the idea of hey why don't
we build an app for magic League one now
I got to preface this by saying that
none of us are 3d application developers
we're not modelers or graphics artist or
game designers whatsoever but we are a
series and we know how to build and run
infrastructure and run it reliably at
scale who said hey wouldn't it be really
cool if we can take the infrastructure
that we do and work with day to day and
be able to visualize it using spatial
computing to be able to actually see all
the nodes and show the dependencies and
everything that we're working on so
that's what we decided to do that was
our challenge we wanted to in 24 hours
be able to build and visualized using
terraform our infrastructure and spatial
computing and that's what we did so 24
hours later well about 30 hours actually
but in a day we're able to with no help
no outside help no documentation just
using what our customers see we were
able to build on device having no
previous unity experience and no
previous unreal or anything like that
and it was really empowering an
enjoyable experience like I can't
describe how happy I was the first time
I'd saw this like see of leapers appear
on stage in in 3d in front of me it was
like
like my first hello world all over again
one of the challenges that we faced with
this was not having any outside help we
had to kind of dig within the team and
and leverage each other and really work
work together as a team so I'm gonna
turn it over to Anthony right now he's
going to talk through some of the
technical challenges that we face as a
team as we were trying to build out
infrastructure using mixed reality
thanks Dan
my name is Anthony Lucilla I'm a site
reliability engineer at magically and
the technical lead of nebula we built
this experience using unity and c-sharp
for the multiplayer element we are using
photon which handles the user and room
management as well as synchronization of
object data like position rotation scale
even custom metadata that were able were
able to send using terraform and AC ICD
pipeline we deployed the necessary
back-end components Google Google cloud
functions and Google Cloud Storage this
allowed us to pull terraform state data
which we then parse and visualize in
mixed reality there is so much more that
you can do than simply reading a
terraform state file imagine you could
make changes in real time with terraform
in mixed reality query near live
metadata to facilitate tasks like
architecture reviews cost analysis and
system health monitoring you can even
customize your war rooms with dashboards
comms channels and whatever other useful
information you could fill the room with
and because this is collaborative you
would all see the exact same thing in
that war room in my opinion the most
important part of this experience is
making sure that everyone sees the same
thing in the same place which brings us
to the most complex and interesting
problem that we faced
how do you make sure that every user and
the same experience sees the same thing
each device is independent therefore how
can multiple users in the same
experience know everyone else's position
and orientation where is the origin
there are a few solutions to this
problem our experience solves this using
image tracking the magic leap image
tracking system uses the camera to
detect two dimensional planar images
from a custom defined target set and
continuously tracks and updates its
location and orientation as users move
around in the real world this image
therefore becomes a point of reference a
way for everyone to agree on an
orientation and an origin for the room
in other words through the technical
details let's watch a quick video of
nebula
[Music]
okay we're choosing a room
we've got a couple terraform
architectures to choose from you can
drag it out and into the room and
manipulate their position the red
indicators you see are what other users
and the same experience are looking at
and as you can see other users are also
able to move objects at the same time
and you're able to even try to steal it
from them
and you can also move up to it and
interact with it because it's out there
in the real world thank you right thanks
big round of applause fees for the team
at magically
[Applause]
[Music]